we talked about the process in Ukraine
and my guest tonight is a journalist for
vice news com who witnessed it firsthand
Simon Ostrovsky an American journalist
was freed late last week after being
detained beaten and held captive there
by a pro-russian militia he's here with
us tonight please welcome Simon
Ostrovsky first welcome back thank you
could you have dreamt like a week ago
when you were incarcerated that you
would be appearing on an HBO show you've
never heard of this is completely
ridiculous that is probably the fairest
review we've had so far this is
objectively stupid I want to talk a bit
about slovyansk that that's where you
were it's a town in eastern Ukraine
currently being run by who exactly
because it's not being run by Russia
it's not being run by Ukraine it seems
to be run by just some guy right yeah
he's got gold teeth he used to run a
soap factory he's missing a few fingers
and his name is on the might of and
that's pretty much all we know about him
but he kind of rules the place like his
own fiefdom with an iron fist as I found
out it's pretty he's Conor he seems to
be accountable to no one his first press
conference he told reporters that the
previous legitimate mayor had and I
quote off and he's now the
people's mayor so he's just declared
himself basically governor of that town
I didn't hear him say that and I think
the previous mayor didn't just off
the previous mayor was actually taken
hostage by him and hasn't been seen
since right you know that's one way to
describe he was he was off
do you think is the grammatically
accurate way of putting it she was
off yes she was okay
but it's it seems like a microcosm he
seemed like a microcosm of the chaos in
Ukraine at the moment because he is not
seemingly answering to either of the
sighs you have something that is
potentially incredibly dangerous
it's totally dangerous because not only
do you not know who he's answering to
but you don't even know if all of the
armed men in the streets of slavyansk
are directly answering to him and so
you've got checkpoints that have been
set up all over the city where people
pretty much do what they want and then
if they feel like it they might bring
them over to him and then you know throw
them in a basement for a few days or two
weeks or however they're feeling well
because you've reported a lot about the
fact that it was interesting to me that
it Crimea seemed safer in a way because
at least the Russian army not wearing
Russian army clothes is still a military
that you understand the answers to
somebody right exactly and military
actual military tend to be less excited
about the concept of war than dudes with
guns yeah off the street
no Crimea was felt a lot safer and I
can't believe I'm saying that now
because when I was there Crimea was
really tense but eastern Ukraine and
southern Ukraine especially Odessa now
they're just you know they're going
crazy so what is that what is the
feeling on the ground because you've
been there what do the the citizens
there what do they expect to happen not
necessarily what do they want to happen
what are they expecting this to go like
I don't know what the citizens are
expecting but it looks like it's moving
closer to civil war because every day
there is another violent act that makes
people more angry on either side and
you've got the Russian propaganda
channels demonizing the people who
support Ukrainian unity and you've got
Ukrainian media demonizing the people
who support Russia and it just could
lead to something ugly because this is
what happened a head of the genocide and
Bosnian we're having a head of the
genocide in Rwanda was you had the media
taking sides and telling people that
they needed to fight other people and
that's exactly what's happening in in
Ukraine right now and so I think sort of
at a precipice and it could go either
way and we can only hope that that both
sides pull back and that the world tries
to encourage both sides to pull back and
that the United States tries to
encourage the new leadership in Kiev to
try to maybe understand the pro-russia
people in eastern Ukraine and and listen
to them because right now nobody's
listening to each other because that's
the problem what is the feeling there of
what the Western involvement has been
for because we are meddling you know we
love to meddle I love to say oh I wonder
what would happen if that went there yes
the west's been meddling but the Russian
side has been meddling a lot more
successfully you know the West obviously
supports the interim government but
doesn't have the same tools or the same
grassroots support in Ukraine as Russia
does in the east of Ukraine so
everything that the West has been trying
to get the Ukrainian authorities to do
you know it hasn't really been filtering
through now I was I was reading that
when you were when you're imprisoned you
were there one point with four other
people a journalist a computer
programmer a local politician and a
bodybuilder be honest did you all try
and make friends with the bodybuilder I
was a little bit depressed the day that
I found out he was a bodybuilder because
they told me that they were gonna
release me and they took me upstairs and
instead of releasing me they showed me
to a Russian camera team and then took
me back into the basement so I wasn't
very into the exercises that he was
showing to all of the other guys down
there they'd all been down there for
longer so they were kind of boring used
to the whole situation and I was kind of
like oh I wish I wasn't here I love the
fact that anywhere in the world there's
always going to be a guy with low muscle
mass in glasses going I don't want to be
here while you're exercising though yeah
what is the what is the hope what is
there much hope on the ground or are
they just in a cycle of despair towards
like you say Civil War it's not in a
cycle of despair yeah and I think it
could move away from civil Civil War and
I really hope that it does but the other
day a lot of people died in a fire in
Odessa and that's gonna make people in
the southeast of Ukraine who support
Russia very angry and that's why right
now is the time for everybody to tell
everybody to just chill out I really
appreciate you being here and all your
reporting and I guess if we can take one
thing away from this it's that everyone
should chill the out
in the most in the broadest possible
terms Simon Ostrovsky ladies and
gentlemen